three weeks later we're going to be on
some red carpet somewhere
you know and william morris is going to
call someone to sign us none of that
happened
you've mentioned that a beautiful lesson
for creative people is getting knocked
down
why is that uh sounds uh troubling why
would that be good
well
um
you know
it's it's been said a lot you know
you don't know who you are until you've
been
knocked down and figure out
who you who you are is always in
um how
you get up
and how
gracefully you can get up without
you know retaining uh you know too much
anger and resentment for things
um you're gonna get knocked down in the
film business i don't care
if you're how high up you are
there's gonna be um there's gonna be
issues
and
you
when you when you've been
down
then you know you can get up you know we
had
um a film
that we were going to do that was going
to be this bigger film it was going to
be the one that goes up and up
and it got all the way
to
location scouting everything we had
production offices everything
and something happened and the thing
just the bottom just dropped out of it
and
we literally were in the production
office like they said movies off
we're like
what are we going to do now
and a lot of people just went their
separate ways
and everything else and and
i still remember how
kind of low that felt that
and then it wasn't like you know you try
to save it oh maybe we can go over here
and somebody will do it and
that didn't work so we just had nothing
you know we had to start over from
scratch
and i thought
wow what a great lesson that is
um what a great humbling experience
so i know now that it's not just going
to go just like i want it so we need to
be able to
figure out how to bring yourself back up
from that
and in that is where
you learn
the most valuable lessons in life and in
film
in life obviously it's you know how you
you know
test your your inner strength and
ability to stay focused in film you
learn
how to do things that you were going to
hire three guys to do now you can hire
one guy to do and you learn that you can
do it with the one guy if you help you
learn how these things all work and how
they all
kind of
work together and you become a better
filmmaker that way
so
when
when you get knocked down you know
that's where the lessons are i mean like
i had said before the
you know the first film we just were
kind of on cloud night we didn't know
what was going on we just knew
well you know
three weeks later we're going to be on
some red carpet somewhere
you know and william morris is going to
call someone to sign us none of that
happened so
um the real lessons were learned
after
we had that
thing fought from under us and say okay
now we can rebuild now we can rebuild
with something solid where we know what
we're doing when we know how to get it
done
and we can then look at a
investor or look at a distributor or
someone who's giving an mg or whatever
and say
i know exactly how to get this film done
we don't have to depend on anybody that
we don't know
we know exactly how to get it done and
that confidence
in that gleam in your eye that
confidence
is something that um you know financial
financers want to see
that you're not thinking about how great
you're going to be that you're thinking
about the film you're thinking about
their investment you're thinking about
you know all the elements
and that if something happens
you can fix it
you're not just going to fall apart
on the ground you know how to pick
yourself back up and pick your
production back up and keep it moving
forward that's a much better investment
than
if you've never been knocked down
can you tell when you go to hire someone
or you have an interview with someone
for whatever it is whether it's a script
reading a producer
and there's something in you that knows
that person hasn't been knocked down
and maybe they're not going to weather
[Music]
a tougher or shoot
a little something with a little more
challenge a little more edge to it
absolutely you can tell you can
it's you can tell it right in their eyes
i mean you don't want to be
prejudiced against them meaning in that
way but
it's a lot of times you can tell by what
they ask for
um if they say i need this i need that
and i need this and i and then you say
well we might have that with well how
are we going to do the film if we don't
have that
well if you if you haven't done the film
without that
then you might be on the wrong film
because we may have that
and we may be able to get that
but it can't be like well um
uh you know
i
you know you have you're doing dp stuff
and the guy says well i can't work
without a focus puller
well
most
dps don't want to work without a focus
puller and to have a focus point we have
focus pullers but
the dps that are doing indie films
most of them know that they've at some
point had to pull their own focus
okay so if you get somebody that says
well i've never worked without a focus
puller well that may not be the right
guy for us
because even though we'll give him a
focus puller
we
still it's still
potentially problematic that they
have maybe never been on enough films
and had those kind of experience so if
something happens that for focus puller
you know get sick
or
runs off
or something they can we can still get
the film done and things don't stop
unless things go exactly the way they're
supposed to go so
i think that's a decent example of it
but but it can be a lot of things you
know
um
it's very rare to find an actor that has
not been knocked down that that's very
common they've all had any actor has
dealt with massive amounts of rejection
um
massive amounts of disappointment they
know they were perfect for the role
they did a perfect read and they never
got the call back or they got the call
back and then they gave the part to the
producer's girlfriend or something like
that because
they're they they come in
pretty
strong in that area of things not going
their way
so i give them that credit
to and certainly directors
and filmmakers you know
you go through it constantly of of
having
um you know this is going to go and it
doesn't go and this is going to go and
it's going to go it's one of the reasons
we moved to mexico we just
just
stay stay with them with the real stuff
so based on what someone asks questions
and their needs you can tell how it'll
work out i think so um you know if you
ask the right questions
um
you know i asked
what was the lowest budget movie you've
ever made let's say i'm worth talking a
crew member
say uh have you ever you know have you
done an in if you did student type films
things like that
and that'll kind of inform you as to
you know how cooperative they'll be
and
um
you know
what do you do if there's not enough
time or daylight
what do you do
and well you know we'll just shoot
tomorrow no you can't shoot tomorrow
what are you going to do well they can
always figure something out put the
light up here like this we'll do like
this we'll bring it in close
we'll just uh we'll do the reverse so we
see the sun and then we'll turn around
and light it this way there's all kinds
of things you can do so so you're so
you're always looking for flexibility
you're looking for
people that
that
feel like they can get it done
regardless of the situation in the
scenario you know it's the most
important thing so um
and you know i don't see a lot of people
that are are really
i've had to say you know what
i can't have that person it's not a lot
most people in film have come up through
the same system of with their friends
and in student films and short films and
you know they've seen it all most of the
time so it's not like um
you know people coming out of some
prestigious school where they've never
seen anything i mean you you know you
see people a lot of people go to film
school and you know to sc or ucla and
that's great but everybody knows it it's
on set
um experience is what everybody's
looking for